il y avait de la testostérone réunis
autour de l'accord dès ce vendredi au
centre commercial sqy ouest pour x trem
ascension acte 2 les sapeurs pompiers de
toute l'ile-de-france s'affronter à la
force des bras sur 10 15 et 20 m mode
d'emploi pour les gros bras un démarrage
à 600 que les pieds touchent le sol le
buzzer dans la main et tom décollage
immédiat pour une escalade de 10 mètres
où chacun a ses petits trucs pour
grimper moi personnellement je vais de
forme pour nous et et puis je mets du
balancement des jambes après certains à
ses techniques ses facilités pour monter
plus rapidement
il faut travailler à fond à manger de la
part du fonds à manger pour pouvoir
progresser travailler un petit peu
laissée après essayer d'avoir des
grandes brassées c'est de faire des
grandes brassées et après si tu ceux des
listes et par un mouvement de balancier
en fait des genoux des hanches
voilà pour essayer de deux gagnants
l'ampli pour les meilleurs cédilot
mètres de corde ont été absorbées en un
peu plus de 10 secondes et cela va très
vite
attention âmes sensibles s'abstenir
un défi physique qui n'est pas à la
portée de tout le monde même pour le
parrain 2 x trem l'ascension adepte du
grimper de corde
je me suis essayé alors moi je ne suis
pas l'habitude sur le dise le 15 ouvrir
le vin ne parlant pas je fais 16
secondes je suis assez content ça à
temps moyen par aman j'ai eu un petit
coup de barre à ces deux films est là
c'est pas évident ça reste
impressionnant quand même alors
j'imagine même pas le 20 mètres demain
je vais me tester aux 15 mètres et
encore je doute va mettre impossible